let me ask you almost for fun so this is
not Oriel as as a as a deep mind person
or anything to do with deepmind or
Google just as a human being and looking
at these news of a Google engineer who
claimed
uh that uh I guess the Lambda language
model was sentient or had the and you
still need to look into the details of
this but sort of making an official
report and the claim that he believes
there's evidence that this system is has
achieved sentience and I think
this is a really interesting case on a
human level in a psychological level on
a uh
Technical Machine learning level of how
language models transform our world and
also just philosophical level of the
role of AI systems in
um in a human world so what did you what
do you find interesting what's your take
on all of this as an as a machine
learning engineer and a researcher and
also as a human being yeah I mean a few
reactions
um quite a few actually have you ever
briefly thought is this thing sentient
right so never absolutely like even with
like Alpha star wait a minute what no
sadly though I think yeah sadly I I have
not um yeah I think I think the current
any of the current models although very
useful and very good
um yeah I think we're quite far from
that
um and there's kind of a Converse
Side Story so one of one of the my
passions is about science in general and
I think I feel I'm a bit of a like a
failed scientist that's why I came to
machine learning because you always feel
and you start seeing this that machine
learning is maybe the science that can
help other Sciences as we've seen right
like you you know it's such a powerful
tool
um so thanks to that angle right that
okay I love science I love I mean I love
astronomy I love biology but I'm not an
expert and I've decided Well the thing I
can do better at these computers but
having especially with when I was a bit
more involved in Alpha for learning a
bit about proteins and about biology and
about life
um the complexity it feels like it
really is like I mean if you start
looking at the things that are going on
um at you know at the atomic level
um and and also I mean there's there's
always busy that
we are maybe inclined to try to think of
neural networks as like the brain but
the complexities and the amount of magic
that it feels when I mean I don't I'm
not an expert so it naturally feels more
magic but looking at biological systems
as opposed to this computer
computational brains
just makes me like wow this there's such
level of complexity difference still
right like orders of magnitude
complexity that
um sure these weights I mean we train
them and they do nice things but they're
not at the level of biological entities
brains cells
it just feels like it's just not
possible to achieve the same level of
complexity behavior and but my belief
when I talk to other beings is certainly
shaped by this amazement of biology that
maybe because I know too much I don't
have about machine learning but I
certainly feel it's very far
fetched and far in the future to be
calling
um or to be thinking well these these
these mathematical function that is
differentiable is is um is in fact
sentient and so on so there's something
on that point it's very interesting so
you know enough
about machines and enough about biology
to know that there's many orders of
magnitude of difference and complexity
but you know how machine Learning Works
so the interesting question from human
beings that are interacting with a
system that don't know about the
underlying complexity
and I've seen people probably including
myself that have fallen in love with
things that are quite simple yeah so and
and so maybe the complexity is one part
of the picture but maybe that's not a
necessary
um
that's not a necessary condition for
sentients for um perception
uh or emulation of sentience right so I
mean I guess the other side of this is
that's how I feel personally I mean you
ask me about the person right
um now it's very interesting to see how
other humans feel about things right
this is this we are like
um again like I'm I'm not as amazed
about things that I feel are this is not
as magical as this other thing because
of maybe yeah how I got to learn about
it and how I see the curve a bit more
smooth because I you know like just seen
the progress of language models since
Shannon in the 50s and actually looking
at that time scale we're not that fast
progress right I mean what what we were
thinking at the time like almost 100
years ago
is not that dissimilar to what we're
doing now but at the same time yeah
obviously others might experience right
that the personal experience I think no
one should
um you know I think no one should should
tell others how they should feel I mean
the feelings are very personal right so
how others might feel about the models
and so on that's one part of the story
that is important to understand for me
personally as a researcher and then
when I maybe disagree or I don't
understand or see that yeah maybe this
this is not something I think right now
is reasonable knowing all that I know
one of the other things and perhaps
partly why it's great to be talking to
you and reaching out to the world about
machine learning is hey let's make let's
demystify a bit the magic and try to see
a bit more of the math and the fact that
literally to create these models if we
had the right software it would be 10
lines of code
um and then just a dump of the internet
so versus like then the complexity of
like the creation of humans
um from from their Inception right and
also the complexity of evolution of the
whole universe to where we are
um that is feels orders of magnitude
more complex and fascinating to me so I
think
yeah maybe part of the only thing I'm
thinking about
trying to tell you is yeah I I think
explaining a bit of the magic there is a
bit of magic it's good to be in love or
busy with what you do at work and I'm
certainly fascinated and through price
quite quite often as well but I think
hopefully as experts in biology
hopefully will tell me this is not as
magic and I'm happy to learn that
um through through interactions with the
larger Community we can also have a
certain level of Education that in
practice also will matter because I mean
one question is how you feel about this
but then the other very important is
you're starting to interact with these
in products and so on
um it's good to understand a bit what's
going on what's not going on
um what's safe what's not safe and so on
right otherwise
um the technology will not be used
properly for good which is obviously the
goal of all of us I hope